I don't think that anyone other than
Donald Trump would fight back this way
and I think that's why he is the right
man for the job at this specific moment
in time is there any president you would
rather have in office in 2019 woke
culture than Donald Trump question of
the day to those who weren't okay let me
preface this I was going to be talking
about the Ukraine scandal and kind of
the top five takeaways today I just
wanted to talk with you guys about
something personally a little bit let me
take a minute so question before I get
to this so those of you out there who
weren't Trump fans initially okay maybe
maybe you're not even Trump fans now
maybe you supported someone else in the
primary I did if you thought president
Trump would be a disaster as many of you
did do you know knowing what you know
now knowing better do you think that
maybe you were wrong do you think that
maybe and I will say this I do now do
you think maybe for this moment in time
he is uniquely he is the only person for
the job
let me summarize it I don't realize
never too many question there was like
nine questions today so in summary I'm
getting very near the end of this now
named that film they met movie line do
you guys know wait for the comment
section to summarize who did you support
in 2016 and has your opinion changed so
let me set some context here especially
in the wake of Russia in the wake of
Cavanagh now you have the Ukraine
I really am at the point where I think
that President Trump is the only person
who could serve the purpose of
highlighting the media and entertainment
industrial complex whatever you want to
call it that's what I call it and the
media entertainment industrial complex
because I like to jiu-jitsu that they're
bias let's um let's take you know more
recently both Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani because I know Giuliana's been
getting a lot of flak lately granted he
comes across as a little bit nutty
certainly ornery like he almost in every
single interview zamyla must be thing
look go yourself like he always seems
upset I get it but if you watch his
interviews it's been pretty easy
obviously for the media to try and and
use him to say he's unhinged but because
of Donald Trump he's at least in part
been emboldened in going after the media
at this point which I appreciate watch
his interview with Chris Cuomo was
trending all over
Twitter and I'm going away are people
seeing the same thing that I'm seeing
this is from a couple weeks ago
is he grumpy sure but he was hammering
Chris Cuomo and the media in a way that
he never has in the past and I think
that's in large part because he was he
was sort of the Republican that the
leftist needed a liberal media gave it
pass to for a good chunk of time after
9/11 remember he was the man of the year
he's not pro-life I think at one point
he was there was him and Fred Thompson
and they thought Rudy Giuliani was going
to be the guy I think before McCain er
before Romney I think was before McCain
so he's been seen as a pretty moderate
Republican and so the media kind of saw
him is a useful tool and I think this is
just opinion here that maybe mayor
Giuliani actually believed that
Republicans could play nice with the
media in Hollywood but because these
people now have they hate Trump so much
on such a visceral and personal level
they've attempted to lay waste to anyone
even associated with President Trump and
I think it's woken up
mayor Giuliani I think he's probably
said to himself wait wait I was the
moderate Republican to whom he gave a
pet now you're gonna treat me this way
okay the gloves are off and I think it's
been a real awakening for him and I
think that President Trump has served
that same role for a lot of people I let
me full disclosure I wasn't a Trump guy
in the primaries and sometimes I do I
would wish that other conservatives
would go after the media as passionately
as Trump and Giuliani has been recently
think of tried and true conservatives
out there I don't want to throw anyone
in the bus or name is but people who are
hyper ly intelligent quick-witted and I
would think to myself you know if only
they just went after the the media the
entertainment industry was with the same
vigor that Trump does and if you combine
it with their more sort of articulate
brand of conservatism we'd be aces but
they don't and that's because a lot of
them are parties I have to believe that
that's just we've been waiting for a guy
or a gal to do this for a long time and
it's not ideal but President Trump is
not only the best we've got
he's the only guy we've got so with
President Trump and Giuliani right now
you at least have people who are willing
to point out the hypocrisy with let's go
to Ukraine Biden right point out the
corruption
the media's biased which I just I think
is really valuable I think it's
singularly unique to president Donald
Trump regardless of where you line up if
he's your guy if you think he's a
bloviating jackass and none of those
opinions are invalid I know and I know
that many of you out there by the way
are new to the conservative movement or
the sort of right-wing anti woke culture
red pill whatever you want to call it
and I'm really glad you're here okay
we've seen the numbers we've seen the
demographic shifts on YouTube I can't
thank you enough but you do need to know
something conservatives have talked
about this forever and by this I mean
media bias and we've talked about just
how pervasive just how corrosive it is
we conservatives have always talked
about this it's almost the primary
beeping point of a conservative movement
for decades but it was mostly relegated
to just the enclaves of political
hobbyists maybe a few think tanks
because of President Trump not anymore
not anymore everyone talks about it and
I do think that is exclusively because
of the guy in the White House right now
so you think of this for a second okay
to put a finer point on it outside of
the hyperlink age political
conservatives okay put them on the side
before President Trump all the way up
until 2016 and I'm not exact I mean this
literally all the way up until the 2016
election CNN was seen as a down the
middle legitimate news network CNN the
reason it plays in airports and public
spaces that's that's their sole
viewership by the way whenever you go
what's the viewership and say well I
don't know do we count all the airports
and sports balls where they're playing
the reason that's the case is because
for a long time unlike Fox News and
MSNBC CNN was seen as just a truthful
centrist news network now let me rewind
this for a little bit of context okay in
2015 a lot of conservatives in this
industry the media industry people who
are writers think-tank folk commentators
whatever it is political consultants I
don't know what that means it means that
you'll have a real job and someone liked
you and so they give you a stipend but a
lot of conservatives in the industry
they would kind of joke but they weren't
really joking they would say that if
Trump won it wasn't going to be good for
their job security and I heard this from
people who were executives at
conservative networks and this is
because usually being a voice of
opposition being sort of a counter
Authority is
most always more lucrative for opinion
journalism right because you're fighting
the power but if you go back and I
encourage you to run a search on my
YouTube channel here if you go back to
2014 2015 2016 well I mean assume
assuming the youtube search gets fixed
so I don't know you know it just might
be difficult you might be able to find
it you might not you might have to go on
my channel here and click date added and
go through ones that you can go through
relevancy or you can go through time
like it the point is it'll be difficult
but I want you to I want you to call me
on this go back to 2015 to 2016 and I
said this I said if Trump wins our enemy
doesn't change
I mean meaning the villain of the
American public that doesn't change it's
still the media the entertainment
industry elects that's a mouthful media
entertainment industrial complex media
entertainment industrial complex
I don't know Bernie Sanders says that
was the military-industrial complex but
you know good for you Bernie so but that
is what it is and it is a complex of
media and the entertainment industry
there did one on the same I remember
saying listen if Trump wins it doesn't
change anything because the primary
villain the primary I guess you would
say dark force it's the media it's in
they're going to be out in full force
they're going to be out even they're
gonna be more aggressive if President
Trump wins and this is something I think
people need to understand and they
missed a lot at Fox and a lot of think
tanks because I thought Obama's
president right now and so this is a
good time for us to to raise more money
because we're fighting the man the
authority ok the propagandists in charge
in large part of American discourse if
it wasn't Barack Obama wasn't Nancy
Pelosi it largely has nothing to do with
the person who's holding office at that
moment in time it is the media it is the
entertainment industry and I should say
no at least it was I think that's
changing I think that's why even though
you this this flies in the face of what
traditional media experts would say that
Donald Trump a Republican as president
we've still grown more than ever before
it's the same reason that now YouTube
and Google wants to blacklist our
content because they know who's pulling
the strings I wasn't a trump thin okay
but let me ask you this does anyone
actually think that any of the other
candidates would have
the media the way that President Trump
has can you think of Annie anyone
genuinely in the Republican Party who
would hammer the media in the
entertainment who would just live to
expose them as relentlessly and
vigorously as Donald Trump I can't I
honestly can't think of a single one
which is a huge part of me that thinks
and I know I know I can already see this
on media matters that's why a big part
of me thinks that President the
presidency of Donald Trump is almost
providential and I'm not saying he's
perfect in the Bible says God God can
use an ass not saying jumps an ass but
he could be he certainly is sometimes
let me use a more recent example okay to
highlight this point let's go to Ukraine
here's the thing I think former Vice
President Joe Biden I think he's a goof
but I don't necessarily think that he's
guilty of anything that would disqualify
him from running for president certainly
not anything that would warrant forcibly
removing him from office if it had been
discovered while he was vice president
but let me recap this here just so we
understand this was a segment I was
originally going to do and I thank you
for spending the time with me as I just
sort of let off some hopefully hopefully
it's insightful I have no idea it's me
talking to a camera okay hunter Biden
let's go hunter Biden he got a job with
Ukrainian company energy company 50,000
a month he was being paid a job for
which he had zero qualifications you're
thinking hold on are you exactly
some qualifications no no qualifications
a prosecutor was assigned to investigate
the business dealings with Biden son
Vice President Joe Biden went on
publicly claimed and bragged that he
withheld aid in order to pressure the
firing of the prosecutor the prosecutor
was fired the investigation stopped now
when asked President Joe Biden a sorry
vice former vice presidential but it's
not the LGBTQA I he can I just say Joe
Biden do I have to say we have to say
senator every time someone like you
served one term congratulation
you've got your pension you have to call
you senator for the rest of your life
former Vice President Joe Biden when he
was asked he said that he never
discussed any foreign business dealings
with his son then there was evidence
that emerged of Biden hanging out with
his son and those with whom his son can
ducted business on a regular basis at
golf outings together now let's assume
that all of this is 100% of
misunderstanding okay well Donald Trump
- to recap is accused of threatening to
withhold foreign aid unless they were
bending to his will
however instead of bragging about it
publicly Donald Trump denied it the
transcripts that he released at the very
least leave reasonable doubt that he was
not withholding funding specifically to
try and gather dirt on Joe Biden and
Ukrainian officials mind you have
confirmed that the only hiccups that
occurred with foreign aid and they did
occur but they occurred long after that
phone call took place
so unless Donald Trump or the Ukrainian
officials had a DeLorean where they
could see that a few days down the line
or a few weeks down the line there was
going to be withholding a military aid
or some kind of it they couldn't know
contextually they couldn't know here's
my point
you cannot impeach President Donald
Trump and let Joe Biden slide that's not
what about ISM this is what the media
wants to do that's important that is
important to note you could not have a
more clear-cut comparison of something
that a media darling did and something
that President Donald Trump did now I
think if it were anyone other than
Donald Trump I think I you take your
pick I think if it was Marco Rubio I
think if it were Jeb JEB Jeb Bush I was
once a Jeb w Jeb Bush I think they would
say well I didn't do anything wrong and
they would slide away into the darkness
hoping that it blows over Donald Trump
says no no no no no no this is what
Biden did let's hold me to the same
standard you're holding them to hold on
a second hold on a second you're gonna
do this with Kavanaugh
let's bring up Bill Clinton let's bring
up wanita broader you swept her under
the rug I don't think that anybody else
and it could be for reasons that are
petty it could be for his own selfish
motives but it doesn't matter I don't
think that anyone other than Donald
Trump would fight back this way and I
think that's why he is the right man for
the job at this specific moment in time
is there any president you would rather
have in office in 2019 woke culture than
Donald Trump I don't mind the
polarization I think he's a I think he's
a stellar litmus test right now because
even if he's offensive at least you know
somebody's a grown-up if they say he's
not so
offensive to me that I want him
impeached for something that he didn't
do and here's the thing if Democrats at
the left were being actually honest and
they just said you know what we we want
to impeach Donald Trump on articles of
being an ass at least at least they'd be
honest your honor how does he play well
he's a prick I at least I think everyone
in the country would say you know what
okay maybe he's an ass but he's our ass
and he's an ass who pisses off the ASPS
who are evil far more effectively than
anyone else we could have put in office
I know it's weird to think of someone
who being providentially perched into
that position because he's an ass
but that's what I believe I hope you
enjoyed this video that the part of the
whole show that you didn't see was our
entire Ash Wednesday episode in which we
discussed how politics intrudes on non
political parts of life such as sports
movies TV celebrities so all three of us
sat down here for about an hour you only
get access to that if you are a member
of Mudd Club of course signed up at the
blaze in other words do that now enjoy